good to see you Mr zofka this morning
counter-offensive going slower than hope
says Mr zielinski is that because
Ukraine needs more Weaponry or because
the Russians are stronger than you
anticipated you know it's certainly not
because Russians are stronger but it
certainly is because we need more
Weaponry uh because counts are offensive
and the previous counter-offensive we
already had throughout the last half a
year and the previous defense defensive
actions in donbass they require
ammunition artillery Western type things
and armored vehicles so yes we need more
but at the same time this
counter-offensive is much more difficult
because really Russians are prepared
much more prepared regions which we are
now having as a counter-offensive object
so the defense system is strong but we
are certainly outnumbering they are
outnumbering us in the Manpower and we
are much better in having the quality of
our armed forces and the tactics of our
Armed Forces that's why definitely it is
counter offensive will end with their
success
you're here in London president
zielinski has been visiting many
countries which countries in particular
do you want to see more from and what in
particular are you asking for
well each and every country supports and
helps us in its way uh it's not only
about Military Support by the way
Military Support is crucial as of today
but the support in terms for instance
our integration to U.S NATO and NATO are
is known as important because we really
contributing to the security system of
the European continent and your Atlantic
area we would like to be a part of of
your of your of your system the same
goes about sanctions I mean sanctions
are matter and sanctions do already harm
to Russian economy but not up to the
mark so that's why additional packages
of sanctions that offer you as well as
UK and us are needed so my president uh
will continue probably to have those
visits if the situation on the
battlefield allows because when he
travels when he has his negotiations
with a with the leaders
or eye to eye it's much better and the
results are immediate military packages
Financial supports joining the U.N NATO
um
Sergey shoigu has promised Putin a
reserve Army by the end of the month
does that worry you is that realistic
you know Russia really has a bigger much
bigger population and definitely they
can make another several waves of
mobilizations
they may enlarge their Manpower
um twice or three times or four times or
whatever but again uh this this Russian
aggression they thought they will
outnumber us and they're really
outnumbers in Manpower and equipment and
artillery and ammunition but we are
fighting for our own land our morale is
much more higher soldiers know that they
are defending their Villages their
cities their towns they are motherland
what are Russians fighting for
I don't know that you will receive a
clear answer for us so from a soldier or
from a member of a Wagner group from a
prisoner which thinks who thinks that he
can escape from prison being on the
battlefield we are fighting for our land
and that's why we're gonna win
the kakovka dam
in your mind in terms of the risk of
there being a Russian attack perhaps a
false flag Russian attack on the
zaparisian nuclear plant is is that
increased in your mind
yes kakovka was a pre-planned terrorist
attack a planned by Russia probably from
the first day of open aggression because
they occupied kahov Academy the first
days of open aggression and controlled
it all the time they had the Personnel
at the station they had their military
presence there so that's why absolutely
no doubts that they made this terrorist
attack which caused a terrible Echo site
so we would like all the International
Community to join our efforts in
condemning these terrorist attack and
have been asked to to to to liquidate
the the optimals while if the world will
be keeping silence yes there will be
free in their actions including on the
operation nuclear power plant my
President yesterday told about enough
evidence that they are planning this
operation so the world has to take it
really seriously the Parisian nuclear
power plant is the biggest nuclear power
station in Europe six uh nuclear units
we have to not to repeat the mistakes of
you know sitting and and keeping silence
and watching what will happen this time
the world should react in advance
are you happy that the UK government has
been good to its word in its support of
Ukraine yes absolutely we're thankful
for the UK government and many for many
reasons yesterday uh this very important
Ukraine recovery conference has
concluded and that we have very good
results we have a storage financial
support storage Financial pledges to to
Ukraine UH 60 billion uh including 50
billion from the European commission 3
billion from the UK government and the
rest of the government this is real
support in times of War but already now
we have to plan how to recover Ukraine
how to reconstruct how to relaunch the
economic system the accent was made on
energy and another very important issues
private business was here so this is
real support but before that really
really my president met several times
with prime minister sunaka both think
even here in the UK and he thanked him
for the military support for the long
region artillery for other pieces of
equipment for the support of UK on
Ukraine's journey in NATO this is very
important to form a very strong
decisions at Vilnius Summit yes Ukraine
will not become a member to Nato before
the victory but right now it's high time
to start the procedure of inviting
Ukraine to Nato where already
contributing to your Atlantic security
we deserve to be here we've given Refuge
to very many ukrainians here what is the
message to the Ukrainian diaspora who
have fled to different countries around
the world can they plan to start going
back to Ukraine or do they need to focus
on building their lives where they are
now no no they definitely have to be
back to Ukraine to to to help all of us
to rebuild uh the prosperous European
country uh Ukraine which will be among
the members of the European and Euro
Atlantic feminine certainly when
security conditions allow they certainly
need to go back and to be
ukrainians European ukrainians having
achieved experience communicating to
your people I find Ukrainian people in
each and every Capital this is in fact
the integration of ukrainians to Europe
so after the victory to be back and to
help to restore Ukraine